the arctic blast gripping more than 220
million Americans is forecast to bring
more record-breaking low temperatures
today freeze warnings are up as far as
Southeast Texas with winter weather
advisories up as far north as Michigan
some areas saw a temperature drop of 40
degrees in 24 hours Yanks today promises
to be just as brutal or lead national
correspondent David Beck know is in
Detroit with more on this story Oh
David got the hood on without the big
big coat and the fur coat and the faux
fur this is I said both working this is
for all the people who sit yeah this is
for all the people who send me a social
media message yesterday saying boy put
something on your head I was yelling at
my TV there's a topic in the studio so
we understand that Detroit's about to it
was gonna break a record of its own yep
they in fact did they got more snow at
this time in November than ever before
in fact the last record was set back in
1932 it is 9 degrees here this morning
ladies and gentlemen and there are
people out exercising yeah exercising
running right by us I guess if you live
in Detroit you're used to this kind of
stuff here's what's happened elsewhere
in the last 24 hours
it was an early dose of winter that
coated the roads in Ohio with ice sleet
and snow yesterday leading to crashes
like this one on Interstate 80 which
caused more than 50 car pileup two
people were critically injured drone
video that was shared with our local
station wkb n shows cars and tractor
trailers lined up in the aftermath
bumper-to-bumper in parts of New York
State almost a foot of snow fell in a
48-hour period down south facing a
freeze warning members of Houston's
Bethel Baptist Church controlled the
streets overnight looking for those in
need of shelter and set up cots for them
indoors some people welcomed the winter
weather as it blew through Beach
Mountain North Carolina these college
students broke out skis and a tow rope
and down in New Orleans and the Crescent
City folks were spared some snow but
they bundled up to fend off the near
freezing temperatures and even high
winds at Louis Armstrong International
Airport those gusts made for a dicey
approach for the inbound planes but all
land and sea there were about 5,500
flight cancellations yesterday so get
this the arctic blast stretched all the
way down to the border literally McAllen
Texas right on the border on Monday had
a heat index which is a combination of
what it feels like in the actual
temperature the heat index was 92 within
24 hours it dropped to 31 you know
Anthony Mason I heard you say earlier
that you were feeling the cold in New
York and we are trying to warm up our
sympathy meter David thanks this
dangerous deep freeze will be one for
the record books chief weather caster
Lonnie Quinn of our New York station
wcbs-tv is in New Canaan Connecticut
that's about an hour north of New York
City Lonnie how you doing up there well
well I've got to get a better jacket
because David Beck knows looks way
better than mine but look it's cold it's
cold all over at least 75% of the
country now we're here at the train
station so we've seen a lot of people
bustling and hustling around with their
big coats on the train just left going
into the city I've actually got the
mobile weather lab which is it's a
weather station all the instrumentation
is up top okay I record all my weather
data there it's on four wheels I can
drive it wherever I want it's actually
parked right here on the sidewalk in New
Canaan but it interpolates everything
and take a look at this it brings up a
24 hour temperature change here in New
Canaan it is 35 degrees colder right now
than it was yesterday at this hour
Panama City Florida is 39 degrees colder
so that cold front that came through
yesterday has affected the country from
top to bottom now record record low
temperatures recorded this morning
you've got Washington DC at 26 13 in
Pittsburgh 19 in Birmingham Alabama we
will have record
Lowe's again tomorrow as well you take a
look at some of the numbers 54 of them
Mansfield 28 Richmond at 39 tomorrow
you're looking at two for caribou
Hartford Connecticut 16 the point is the
cold air the record-setting cold is not
going anywhere it's with us again
tomorrow but I believe tomorrow will be
the end of it but in terms of your area
at least for 75% of the country getting
back to normal that is not gonna happen
until about Wednesday of next week so we
just got to get a get used to what we've
got right now guys let's go back to you
in the studio yeah get used to it and
keep reminding yourself it's fall but
Mother Nature has other plans
thank you very much Lonnie